[Music]
kingdom of bhutan
some of our most important magic has his
origins there they say if you listen
carefully enough the past whispers to
you
the world as we know it is coming undone
things that seem unimaginable today
will seem inevitable tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
i imagine that you're all wondering
where you find yourselves here
from this moment forward each of us has
been assigned a role to play if we're to
defeat renewal you'll have to trust me
even when every instinct tells you not
to dumbledore said i give you something
are you kidding me right now
[Music]
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
rescuing me are you
oh well done
[Music]
i have to save the world are we not to
worry
you'll be perfectly safe
with the knuckles
the guns
today
how will we fulfill our destinies and
transform the world
you're not swiveling properly i'm
swiveling out you're serving it
i don't believe you are
[Music]
you